-You look gorgeous.
Welcome back.
-I feel like such a letdown
after Dolly.
I can't even --
-Oh, stop.
Oh, come on. No.
I mean, how ama--
I know, we were --
You were freaking out backstage.
-I know, but I just feel --
I mean, I'm so happy
that she was sat here.
[ Laughter ]
-She's sitting in the same --
Oh, stop it.
-No, I'm just -- I'm so sorry.
For real.
-[ Laughter ]
-Well, you're a big music fan.
We were talking last time.
You were saying how much
you love Bruce Springsteen.
-Every time I'm here.
-Yeah, and then you were going
to go see him in Broadway.
-Yeah, but I didn't, no.
'Cause I very stupidly gave
my ticket to my mother.
[ Laughter ]
-Oh, you're so nice.
No, don't make that face.
You're so happy. You're the
nicest daughter in the world.
-I mean,
she's great, she's great,
but, yeah, no, I regret it.
[ Laughter ]
-But you were saying also that
I think,
it's your favorite
Christmas song as well.
-Oh, yeah, "Santa Claus Is
Coming to Town."
-♪ You better watch out ♪
-The live version when he starts
laughing though.
-Yes. Oh.
"Hey, Ben, you been good
this year?"
[ Laughter ]
-I love it.
-Look, fans of "The Crown,"
by the way, got very excited
because you had a cameo.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Come on, buddy. You came back.
You came back and gave us
a little treat.
-They literally can't get
rid of me.
-No, we were so happy to see it.
But I don't think
anyone was excited as --
You know who was the biggest fan
of you is Nicki Minaj.
And I'm going to read you
a quote.
-I know. You're all laughing.
It's ridiculous.
-[ Laughter ]
-I'm going to read you
a quote from Nicki Minaj.
She said, "I can't get enough of
Claire Foy's perfect face.
I want to eat it."
-[ Laughter ]
"It just does the right thing
in every single scene."
Aw, she loves your face.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Nicki Minaj wants to
eat your face.
-I would totally let her
eat my face.
-You would let Nicki Minaj
eat your face?
-She could try --
I mean, she'd gnaw a bit.
-She could gnaw on it,
yeah, of course.
But also, you know, what I was
thinking, is maybe you can
rap with Nicki because last time
you were here, you rapped.
-Yes, I was forced to.
-I politely asked you to.
-[ Laughter ]
-You were like this
with a microphone.
-Yeah. Do it, do it, do it.
-It was, like, the most
terrifying thing I've ever done.
-But you did Sugarhill Gang.
You did -- It was amazing.
-By muscle memory.
I wasn't really there
in the room.
I was floating above myself,
going, "What are you doing?"
What's wrong with you?"
-[ Laughter ]
-"What are you doing?
You have a great career.
Why are you doing this?"
-"Why are you ruining it?"
[ Laughter ]
-But you did it,
and you crushed it.
Everyone loved it.
-Hey.
-Nicki, just saying --
-Oh, my God, Nicki.
Don't ruin your career by
letting me anywhere near it.
-[ Laughter ]
-Oh, my gosh.
Can we talk about --
You're fantastic, yet again,
in a movie this time.
This is "Women Talking."
-Yes.
-It's already --
-[ Cheers and applause ]
-Very good.
-It's getting awards buzz
already.
This is based on the book
by the same name.
What was your first reaction
to the story?
-So, it's actually --
Yeah, it's a book written by
a Canadian author called
Miriam Toews,
but it's based on a set of
real-life events that happened
in a Mennonite colony in Bolivia
where women from the ages of 4
to, you know, 90 were waking up
and having no memory, and it
turned out that they were being
sexually abused by
men of the colony.
So that's what the base --
Oh, God, it's really --
It's a downer, but that's what
the book is based on, that,
but then the film is
based on the book.
And it sounds incredibly intense
and hard and difficult,
but actually the film is
really tender
and full of love
and hope and stuff.
-Yeah, it's a very difficult
conversation.
[ Cheers and applause ]
It's done very, very well.
And I will say there's one scene
in particular,
where you're doing
this monologue
and you're crushing it.
And I read somewhere --
am I making this up? --
it was like 100 takes
or something?
-We did the first big section of
it 120 times.
-Maybe on the 50th take, do you
go, "I think we got this one"?
[ Laughter ]
-No, because what would happen
is we'd do a day and a half
on one side, and everyone would
go, "Oh, thank God."
And then they'd go "turning
round" and the cameras would go
to the other side, and we'd just
look at the other actors and go,
"I'm so sorry.
You've got to do it all again."
-You have to do it again.
-Yeah.
-Oh, my goodness.
-But it was great.
Amazing actors.
Watching amazing acting.
-The whole movie, everyone,
the cast.
I mean, amazing performances.
-Really amazing.
-But, in particular, Claire Foy.
I'm just saying.
-He has to say that.
-[ Cheers and applause ]
-Just saying.
-A couple scenes, you're doing
this incredibly dramatic work
and then you're going
from crying to laughing.
And I go, "Who can do that?"
That was very impressive.
-Well, the crying is easier than
the laughing.
We were all quite scared about
doing the laughing
because we knew that
we had to do it.
And you know, like, when you
watch something and someone's
laughing and it's not quite
reaching their eyes.
That's the fear of an actor
'cause it's like,
"I'm not finding this funny
at all
and I'm being made to laugh."
But they didn't have
Rooney Mara,
who, turns out, she's a genius.
We were all sat there doing
this scene, and we're thinking
"It's coming up, it's coming,
it's coming up."
And then somebody broke wind.
[ Laughter ]
But we did the nervous thing
of like,
[ Laughing nervously ]
"Someone's actually just farted
in the scene."
But it turns out Rooney had
brought a fart machine in,
and she was sat there going...
-[ Laughter ]
-Like, with the fart machine
picking the moment when we could
all laugh.
-No.
-Yeah, it was amazing.
-Oh, not bad.
That's how you did it?
-Yeah. Really recommend
the fart machine.
-Rooney, good job.
-Yes, good job, Rooney.
-I'm so happy every time
you come here. Please come back.
Congrats on the great reviews
on this.
I want to show everyone a clip.
Here's Claire Foy
in "Women Talking." Take a look.
-We must consider this.
-No. No.
That is not our responsibility
because we aren't in charge of
whether or not
they are punished.
We know that we've been attacked
by men, not by ghosts or Satan,
as we were led to believe
for so long.
We know that we've not imagined
these attacks.
That we were made unconscious
with cow tranquilizer.
We know that we are bruised
and infected and pregnant
and terrified and insane,
and some of us are dead!
We know that we must protect
our children
regardless of who is guilty.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Claire Foy, everybody.
"Women Talking" is
in select cities December 23rd
and nationwide in January.